only ET has the latest on Mariah Carey  and James Packer split rumors the  singers rep exclusively tells ET Mimi  has not seen her fiance since they had a  fight during their trip to Greece last  month but James and Mariah have yet to  call it quits quote the fight was not  because of any cheating allegations or  excessive spending by Mariah James is  one of the most successful businessman  in the world they are trying to work it  out right now they're not sure if they  will stay together billionaire  businessman pop the question in January  with a massive 35 carat diamond ring and  the pop diva was spotted still wearing  her engagement ring at her halloween  party in LA over the weekend Mariah's  rep says the two plan to release an  official statement once they determine  their future together  you